Дві фабрики Рошен. Набережна Рошен. Навіть фонтан Рошен.
На Вінниччині щільно сконцентровані підприємства,
пов’язані з чинним президентом Петром Порошенком.
На них працюють тисячі людей.
Вінниччину називають політичною вотчиною Порошенка -
звідси в 98-му році його вперше обрали  народним депутатом.
Вінниччина вже багато років підтримувала і Порошенка, і його команду.
67% голосів
віддали жителі регіону Петру Порошенку у2014-ому році на президентських виборах.
Це був найкращий результат у країні.
Проте, за 5 років високий рівень довіри скотився з 67% до 22-х відсотків.
Більшість опитанихDW жителів Вінниці поясняють це невиконанням обіцянок.
Нічого не виконав зовсім.
Не продав, збагатився, скажімо так, сам, а Україна поки…
Не можна сказати, що нічого не робив, але з того, що пообіцяв, нічого не виконав.
А що хорошего в нас є.
Маленькі зарплати, маленькі пенсії у пенсіонерів.
Я не бачу дій, і дуже багато брехні.
Я вважаю, що це безумство. Тому що єдиний президент – це Порошенко.
Люди не розуміють, що він зберіг країну.
Можливо, через те, що війна, і всі розуміють, щоякщо буде не Порошенко,
то війна, можливо, закінчиться, щоз Путіним буде хтось говорити, але не Порошенко.
На Вінниччині 8 виборчих округів. У трьох з них чинний президент переміг.
Я не вважаю, що дуже мало зібрав діючий президент в такій ситуації, в якій він опинився.
Коли всі шукають тільки погане
і не говорять про те, що Україна зробилапри ньому, то це дуже хороший результат.
62-річний житель Вінниці Петро Українець у2014-ому році голосував за Петра Порошенка.
Він був на Майдані, потім - на війні на Донбасі.
Працював військовим психологом, був свідком подій біля Широкиного у лютому 2015-го.
Він уважно спостерігав за усіма скандалами,
пов’язаними з грошима президента або корупційними скандалами в його оточенні.
31 березня він віддав свій голос не за Порошенка.
Це його громадянська позиція. Але і не за Зеленського.
Це вже його позиція як психолога з 35-річним досвідом,
який вважає кількамісячне телевізійне годування аудиторії
проектами Зеленського дуже небезпечним.
Сміх
це дуже підлий
спосіб-прийом. Чому? Тому що коли Ви смієтеся –ви не критичні.
Ви знаходитеся в сп’янінні від сміху.
Не лише штаб Зеленського, на думку Петра Українця,
зловживав різними психологічними маніпуляціями.
А і штаби інших кандидатів, і та ж Росія, яке, на думку чоловіка, веде свою інформаційну війну.
Це відіграло велику роль на тлі невдоволення населення політикою президента.
Ви бачите, що відбувається з тарифами. Ви бачите, що відбувається з соціальними питаннями.
Адже політика держави, по суті, стала антисоціальною.
Ви бачите те, що вібувається з бізнесом.
Люди просто перестали бачити і відчувати,
що з цими людьми може бути якась перспектива чи якась реальна трансформація суспільства.
У Вінниці дуже сподіваються,
що напередодні другого туру кандидати представлять чіткі плани дій,
розкажуть суспільству про свої здобутки та потенціал.
Хай Зеленський представить свою програму, що він може.
І хай Порошенко представить свою. Щоб люди бачили різницю.
Явка у першому турі президентських виборів на Вінниччині на деяких дільницях сягала 70% -
уперше після референдуму про незалежність.
Чи буде так багато людей на дільницях у другому турі – в комітеті виборців сумніваються.
Багато що можуть вирішити дебати, які поки не призначені.
Від цього може залежати і явка, і позиція майже 30% виборців,
які на Вінниччині 31 березня не голосували.